Кожне покоління, кожна епоха
намагається одягнути у свої джинси.
Маємо на наших іконах зображення Христа
згідно з візантійським обрядом, візантійської модою.
Малювали те, що їм було більш-менш
прийнятне в одязі того часу, так?
Тобто це воно і є.
Тобто якщо хтось зараз буде
малювати Христа в джинсах,
то він повторить ті речі,
які давно вже вигадані.
Він буде оригінальний, але...
Так, може малювати.
Моєю метою є говорити про Бога сучасним людям.
Тим, яким цікава українська традиція,
традиційна ікона, необов'язково українська.
І у такий спосіб немов євангелізувати.
Євангелізувати в отакий спосіб —
через мистецтво, через те, що я роблю.
♪ [лунає музика] ♪
Тут працюють художники-оформлювачі.
Це майстерня, де вони оформляють усі наші виставки.
Тобто це і роботи, і певний дизайн
виставок, й обладнання.
Все це створюється тут.
І тому тут такий розгардіяш.
Це була ілюстрація до книжки «Це теж зробила вона».
Це Смарагда Ніжинська.
Це свята Православної церкви.
І тут я намагався стилізувати більше
під народну чернігівську ікону.
У тому регіоні зображають
такі характерні ружі, променисті німби.
Це народна ікона з Буковини.
Десь пограниччя Покуття і Буковини.
Кінця ХІХ століття.
Це така дуже своєрідна стилістика,
дуже характерна.
І це якраз та стилістка,
яка свого часу мене дуже захопила.
І, власне, коли я починав малювати,
то відштовхувався від цих ікон.
Намагався робити їх копії.
Вчився копіювати ці ікони, переймати ту техніку.
Ось це наше приміщення —
одне з моїх улюблених у Львові.
Я ще коли вчився в Богословській академії, що
тепер УКУ, дуже захопився іконами в якийсь момент.
І, власне, в мене декілька друзів тут працювали.
І справді, я завжди хотів тут бути.
І от зараз вже 15 років тут працюю.
І дуже щасливий з того.
Українська ікона показує
багатство різних впливів, різних шкіл.
Але також є таким доволі
однорідним явищем.
Ми можемо говорити про українську
ікону, починаючи з «Софії Київської».
Потім ми маємо Галицькі ікони XIV, XV, XVI століть.
які в Національному музеї,
зокрема, гарно представлені.
Ми маємо ренесансну традицію української ікони.
Наприклад, Львівську, Київську, Волинську.
Ми маємо барокові ікони,
академічні ікони, пізньобарокові ікони.
І із Заходу, і зі Сходу.
Ми маємо дуже багату народну традицію іконопису.
І навіть зараз, коли дивишся на ікони,
наприклад, Наддніпрянські ХІХ століття,
Подільські ХІХ століття,
Чернігівські ХІХ століття,
і, наприклад, десь з теренів Галичини,
то бачиш дуже багато спільних речей.
— Привіт!
Кожен художник, кожна творча людина,
не працює виключно для себе.
Я не вірю в мистецтво заради мистецтва.
І що це тільки тобі потрібно.
І ти не розраховуєш на якийсь відгук,
на якусь віддачу від інших.
Я надихаюся народною іконою,
народним іконописом.
Я починав з того, що копіював чи, радше,
намагався наслідувати народні
гуцульські, буковинські, покутські ікони.
У певний момент мені стало
цікавіше розвиватися далі.
Я знайшов певну свою мову в тому.
Приходиш часом з роботи, сідаєш і малюєш.
Я можу бути злим, я можу бути роздратованим.
Я можу бути щасливим і спокійним, змученим тощо.
Тобто емоції можуть бути дуже різні.
Але я маю бажання і потребу,
а тому сідаю й працюю.
Тобто це як елемент життя.
Ти рибкам їсти давала?
Давала?
Можеш їм сипонути [корму]?
Я собі ніколи не вигадую якоїсь концепції:
що я малюю, для чого і що це має означати.
Але мимоволі виходить, що я намагаюся
робити тих святих без такого бар'єру.
Без ієрархічного бар'єру,
якщо так можна сказати.
Тобто наблизити їх.
Поставити їх на коліщатка, намалювати
їм рум'янця, намалювати їм усмішку.
Намалювати їх у таких ситуаціях,
які є нам близькі.
Тобто це такий спосіб
пошуку друзів у тих святих людях,
намагання уподібнитися, наблизитися.
От щось таке.
Ні, я не малюю ідеально, я не маю
взагалі професійної мистецької освіти.
Але я намагаюся досягти того,
що мені подобається.
Мені залежить на тому,
щоб хтось, дивлячись на мої ікони,
а в ідеалі молячись
за посередництвом моїх ікон,
отримував добрі емоції, добрі думки,
добру молитву, добрий настрій.
Якщо навіть хтось усміхнеться,
побачивши, це також добре.
Тобто таке тішить.
Оце от усе буде блакитне довкола,
тільки ми Ісусика зробимо червоним.
Тримай.
Я не знаю, чи потрібно продовжувати писати ікони,
чи малювати, я б так сказав.
Допоки хтось це робить,
допоки хтось малює,
допоки комусь це цікаво
і просять намалювати,
замовляють, доти воно є потрібне.
Воно буде мінятися.
Воно буде якось розвиватись
і знаходити свої форми.
Все таки я переконаний, що християнство
знайдеться в тому сучасному світі.
Воно буде мати продовження
і, зокрема, буде мати мистецтво.
І за 100, і за 200, і за 300, і за 1000 років,
допоки існуватиме людство.
Я не знаю, чи колись там,
за умовних 1000 років,
хтось буде робити ікони такі,
які ми собі зараз уявляємо.
Але я впевнений, що в тогочасній,
скажімо, церкві, мистецтво буде.
Яку воно буде мати форму?
Як воно буде виглядати?
Я не знаю.